let's say you were a 10 time let's say
you were 10-time world champion in Jiu
Jitsu and I was a purple belt you were
black belt 10 time world champion and
you and I were gonna scrap I could go in
like oh I'm gonna get beat and that
could hurt my confidence or I could be
like hey man this guy's a world champion
10 times and he's a black belt and I'm
only a purple belt I'm gonna go in there
try and learn some stuff I'm gonna keep
an open mind watch what he does and I
kind of have nothing to lose so if I
want to throw a move out there I can do
it and if he gets shut down I get tapped
out it's not that big of a deal if you
so so that's the attitude
that will make you able to think and
accept other ideas more is to go in
there with an attitude not of like he's
gonna destroy me and I'm horrible but
like hey I can go in there take some
risks listen learn some moves pay
attention and that's okay